hello and welcome to WWDC 2016 so would
it be great if you could just write your
message on the watch while we're
introducing a new way to do that with
something that we call scribble you can
just quickly draw the letters to your
message right there like writing
something like Starbucks you can see the
letters go right on top of each other
scribble works in English and Chinese
and it knows what language my keyboard
has been set to so with my finger I can
write out a quick message so you might
be having a medical emergency for
example or a safety situation and we're
going to be able to help with that with
SOS on the watch we're going to make it
easy to call for help to activate it you
just press and hold the side button it's
going to count down to let you know it's
calling 9-1-1 and then you're going to
be on a live call with the emergency
services right on your watch so with
watch OS we're introducing activity
sharing you have to do is swipe to the
right of your own activity rings and
there you will see your selected family
and friends rings as well there will be
two workouts in the workout apps
specifically dedicated to wheelchair
users and of course the activity rings
will be optimized for wheelchair pushes
first sling which offers a great
selection of live cable channels is
coming to Apple TV today for sport games
all at the same time on one screen
coming this summer to Apple TV we're
making a new version of the remote app
this is what it looks like it's got a
beautiful now playing screen with
playback controls but most importantly
all the features of the Siri remote when
you go in and you launch a video channel
app for the first time you get something
like this and now we're gonna make it
all go away with a feature we call
single sign-on the name of the world's
most advanced desktop operating system
is now Mac OS our latest newest OS 10 is
Mac OS Sierra for many of us we already
have a device securely authenticated to
our wrists that already knows who we are
and could tell our Mac and so then when
we open our Mac it could be a little bit
more like this
and we're in we turned on all the
switches for optimized storage and we
went from 20 gigs free to 150 gigs free
we're bringing Apple pay to the web you
can push the picture and picture button
your video goes into a nice little pip
how do you like being on a Mac pretty
awesome
lots of space aluminum unibody rolls and
no complaint about the lack of Windows
people really love emoji and now we've
made them three times bigger
we have bubble effects so if you want to
say it loud you can say it loud sport
handwritten messages and when you tap on
the emoji button will highlight all the
Emotiv viable words there and you can
just tap tap tap tap notify this is a
huge moment for us for great platforms
that become even more capable with
working with all of you